sheila's in missouri
hi sheila welcome to dave ramsey show
thank you
thank you for taking my call sure what's
up
question well my brother passed away in
february and he left me some
funds and i don't know what to do with
them we're getting ready to sell the
house
and it's like overwhelming knowing not
knowing what to do
to invest i don't want to invest in
something that's going to buy stocks and
things and
lose money down the line we did that one
time before
okay um how much money did he leave you
um 300 000
and you're selling your home and how
much will you get from it
well we're selling his home um
about 150. so that'll leave you 450 000
from that you've inherited from your
brother okay
in addition to that what do you all have
in this take
we have about 150
000 in savings okay is that in a
retirement account or a savings account
it's in a savings account um earning two
percent
yeah not not much okay all right
and uh do you have any debt uh we only
owe for our truck that we have our home
is paid for
how much do you owe on your truck uh 30
000.
write a check today and pay it off okay
now you have 120 000 in savings
okay now you have no debt uh and out of
that 120 you need an emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses
i think you're a person that would like
six months of expenses
what does it take to operate your home a
month
um usually about maybe
300 400 no it doesn't
you have to eat you have to pay lights
you have to pay insurance on the 30 000
truck you have to pay property taxes
oh gosh i don't know what kind of number
then on that yeah
i'm thinking several thousand dollars a
month of some kind
yeah so calculate what your calculate
your monthly budget
and then multiply that times six and
that's how much out of that 120 that's
left after paying off the truck
i want you to set aside as an emergency
fund i'm gonna call that thirty thousand
for the fun of it
okay i'm just gonna make up a number all
right which leaves us 90 000 there
in that account plus the 450 coming from
your brother did you say your home is
paid off
yes how old are you guys uh
well we are 69. okay cool
most of that is about since my husband
retired
2005. great well you're in very very
good shape
but here's the thing if you take 500
000 which is what we're talking about
here give or take
and you make 10 on it that's 50 000
a year if you make
one percent on it it's 5 000 a year
okay you're losing 45
000 a year
that makes it that makes sense putting
this putting this in a savings account
is financial suicide
now okay then what do i do dave well
i invest only in things i understand
and i get peace about because i get
knowledge about
you did an investment in stocks of some
kind a while back
and you didn't understand it and you got
burned on it
right right we lost it all yes you lost
it all a hundred percent of it
yes wow you did getting a bad deal
that's very unusual that kind of made me
leery
well yeah that'd make me leery too smart
people be leery after that kiddo
all right here's what i want you to do i
want you to learn about
the investment before you do it don't do
it because i said do it or somebody else
said do it don't do it because an
investor said
investment professional said do it do it
because you understand it
click smart investor at daveramsey.com
smart investor and find a smart investor
pro in your area and let them begin to
teach you
only when you understand and have a
comfort level
do you invest and then i would put this
money in mutual funds